>> UKRAINE IS ACCUSING RUSSIA
OF NUCLEAR TERROR AFTER
EXPLOSIONS SHOOK EUROPE'S
LARGEST NUCLEAR POWER PLANT FOR
A 2ND DAY IN A ROW.
UKRAINE SAYS RUSSIAN SHELLS
DAMAGED 3 RADIATION DETECTORS
AT THESE OPERATION NUCLEAR
POWER PLANT, IT CAME JUST A DAY
AFTER AN ATTACK THAT PROMPTED
WARNINGS OF A NUCLEAR DISASTER
FROM THE UN'S WATCHDOG.
RUSSIA BLAMES UKRAINE FOR THE
STRIKES, AND CONCERNS ABOUT THE
PLANT HAVE BEEN GROWING SINCE
RUSSIAN FORCES SEIZED IT IN
MARCH.
UKRAINIAN PRESIDENT VOLODYMYR
ZELENSKYY IS URGING A STRONGER
RESPONSE FROM ALLIES.
TAKE A LISTEN.
>> THERE IS NO SUCH NATION IN
THE WORLD THAT CAN FEEL SAFE ON
A TERRORIST STATE FIRED A
NUCLEAR PLANT, GOD FORBID
SOMETHING IRREPARABLE HAPPENED.
NO ONE WILL STOP THE WIND THAT
WILL SPREAD THE RADIOACTIVE
CONTAMINATION.
THEREFORE, A PRINCIPLED
RESPONSE OF THE INTERNATIONAL
COMMUNITY TO THESE RUSSIAN
ATTACKS ON AND HE SEPARATES YOU
NUCLEAR POWER PLANT, THE
LARGEST IN EUROPE IS NEEDED NOW.
>> AND FOR MORE, WE WANT TO
BRING IN CNN'S NICK ROBERTSON,
HE JOINS US LIVE FROM
CREMATORIA, GOOD TO SEE YOU,
NICK.
SO WHAT IS THE LATEST ON THOSE
STRIKES IN THE NUCLEAR POWER
PLANT IN A SEPARATION?
>> IT IS A STATIC POSITION AT
THE MOMENT, RUSSIA HAS HEAVY
WEAPONS IN PLACE AROUND THAT
NUCLEAR POWER FACILITY.
IT IS AN A TOWN THAT, OR ON THE
EDGE OF A TOWN THAT RUSSIA HAS
TAKEN CONTROL OF, IT IS A
CONTESTED AREA, AND THERE'S NO
DOUBT THAT UKRAINE IS TRYING TO
TARGET RUSSIAN FORCES.
BUT THE IDEA AS RUSSIA ALLEGES
THAT UKRAINE IS FIRING AT THE
NUCLEAR POWER PLANT DOES NOT
SEEM TO STAND UP TO ANY SORT OF
SCRUTINY.
AND, THERE IS A REAL DANGER AS
UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS SAY, AND AS
THE INTERNATIONAL ATOMIC ENERGY
AGENCY DIRECTOR GENERAL HAS
SAID AS WELL, THERE IS A REAL
DANGER THAT SOME OF THE
FACILITIES COULD GET DAMAGED IF
THEY WERE AN ACCIDENT, A
MISFIRE OR SOMETHING LANDED OFF
TARGET NEAR THE FACILITY THAT
HIT PERHAPS THE SPENT FUEL RODS
CONTAINMENT AREA WHICH
ALLEGEDLY HAS BEEN HIT.
IS THERE A REAL RISK OF A
MASSIVE NUCLEAR MELTDOWN ON THE
FRINGES OF EUROPE?
THAT SEEMS VERY UNLIKELY.
IS THIS GOING TO BE A CONTESTED
MILITARY SITE AROUND A VERY
SENSITIVE AREA, YES, AND THAT
SEEMS TO BE THE REASON WHY THE
INTERNATIONAL ATOMIC ENERGY
AGENCY OR CALLING TO HAVE THEIR
INSPECTORS THERE.
IT WOULD CERTAINLY BENEFIT
UKRAINE IF THERE WERE
INDEPENDENT INTERNATIONALIZE
AROUND THAT NUCLEAR FACILITY
WHO WERE ABLE TO SAY, YES,
RUSSIA IS HOSTING ITS HEAVY
ARMAMENTS DANGEROUSLY CLOSE.
BUT, ALL THE SATELLITE
GENERATED INTELLIGENCE AND
IMAGERY ALREADY SUPPORTS --
SEEMS TO SUPPORT THAT CASE.
>> AND, NICK, TELL US MORE
ABOUT THE FIGHTING ON THE
EASTERN, FRONT WHAT ARE YOU
LEARNING.
>> IT IS ACTIVE, THIS IS A VERY
VERY ACTIVE MILITARY REGION,
THE AIR RAID SIRENS AND THE
CITY WE ARE IN, WE ARE NOT AT
THE FRONT LINES HERE, IT GOES
OFF ROUTINELY.
YOU CAN HEAR THE HEAVY IMPACTS
OF SHELLING, I CAN HEAR SOME
NOW, THEY HAVE BEEN GOING ON
SPORADICALLY, THAT IS PROBABLY
MANY, MILES MANY KILOMETERS
AWAY.
BUT AS YOU GET CLOSER TO THE
FRONT LINES, AND YOU CAN HEAR
THE HEAVIEST SHELLING OUTGOING,
AND INCOMING.
THIS IS VERY MUCH AN ARTILLERY
STAND OFF MILITARY FIGHT THAT
IS GOING ON HERE.
DEEP TRENCHES ARE BEING DUG AND
REINFORCEMENTS OR BEING MADE,
BUT IT IS RIGHT AT THE VERY
FRONT LINE WHERE THE REAL HARD
WORK OF SOLDIERS AT THE
TRENCHES IS HAPPENING.
>> DEEP IN THE WOODS AT
UKRAINE'S EAST FRONT, TROOPS
DIG IN, TRENCHES HERE ARE LIFE
SAVERS.
>> WHAT HAPPENED HERE, WHERE
THE FIGHTING IS --
TOOK OUR PORTION OF SHELLING
HERE, AND SOME OF OUR COMRADES
WERE INJURED.
>> THE FACES OF THE TROOPS HERE
TELL A STORY THAT WORD CANNOT
--
THIS IS TOUGH DUTY.
5 DAYS AT THE, FRONT CANDIDATES
RESTING HERE NEARBY.
THEY JOKE ABOUT LIVING LIKE ALL
BETS, UNDERGROUND, AWAY FROM
THE SHELLING.
WHEN UKRAINIAN OFFICIALS TALK
ABOUT THE HIGH MARS ROCKET
SYSTEM AND THE --
ARTILLERY HELPING HOLD THEIR
LINE, THESE ARE THE LINES THEY
ARE TALKING ABOUT.
AND THESE ARE THE SOLDIERS WITH
THE HARD FIGHT TO MAKE SURE IT
DOES HOLD.
>> HE SAYS WE HOLD THE LINE, IT
IS HUMAN, IT RAINS, SHELLS HIT
US ALL THE TIME.
BUT WE HOLD THE DEFENSE.
THERE IS NO OTHER WAY.
>> OF COURSE, THE SHELLING GETS
ON YOUR MIND, HE TELLS ME.
HIS BUDDY VITALI ADDING, BUT
YOU GET USED TO IT.
BOTH SET ON VICTORY, THEY SAY.
TO GET TO THE VERY FRONT LINE,
WE CROSSED FIELDS, LITTERED
WITH RUSSIAN ROCKETS.
ALL OF THESE TREES HERE, THEY
ARE TELLING US THEY WERE TAKEN
OUT BY SHELLING.
CONDITIONS HERE VERY SPARTAN.
THE RUSSIANS LESS THAN A MILE
AWAY, THIS HERE WHEN TROOPS
CANNOT LEAVE THEIR BUNKERS.
RUSSIA RANKS THEM 5 TIMES.
THIS IS WHERE THE NEXT PHASE OF
THE WAR WILL BE, ONE, OR LOST.
IN TRENCHES LIKE THIS THAT
STRETCH FOR HUNDREDS OF MILES,
TROOPS LIKE THIS HOLDING THE
LINE AGAINST THE POSSIBLE
RUSSIAN ADVANCE.
WE MANAGE, THE OFFICER SAYS.
WE HAVE COME HERE TO STOP THE
ENEMY, WE JUST TAKE, IT STATED
OUT, AND KEEP ON FIGHTING.
AN INCOMING SHELL PUNCTUATES
HIS THOUGHT.
MORE, WEAPONS MORE ARMOR HE
SAYS.
IT COULD BE US ADVANCING.
>> SO WHEN I HEAR THOSE SHOTS
GOING OFF, AND WE CAN HEAR THEM
GOING OFF AS THAT STORY WAS
RUNNING, YOU KNOW, WE KNOW THAT
YOUR SOLDIERS RUNNING OFF THOSE
FRONT LINES AND THOSE BUNKERS
TO GET NOSE IN COMING SHELLS
AND WAITING TO RETURN FIRE WHEN
THEY CAN, OUT THERE IT FEELS
VERY MUCH LIKE ROLLED ONE OR
ROLLED WERE TO.
THAT IS THE KIND OF SITUATIO